what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and Marvel
Studios Disney really Disney has updated
their theatrical release slates for 2024
2026 2027 and 2028 29 30 and 31 those
last few are a bit of a stretch they
didn't update the entire slate up until
that point but have a few movies planned
that far out but in this we get an
official release date for Avengers
Secret Wars we also get the current
title for Avengers 5 and Bob Iger during
the earnings call yesterday where all of
this went down did talk about Marvel
studios's new plan for reduced output
Bob Iger and Kevin fige have been
talking about this for some time now and
Bob Iger has made it very clear that he
is trying to change the way the studio
does a few things as far as messaging is
concerned and as far as how many movies
and shows that they're going to produce
for Disney plus so a lot to unpack today
today and a lot is going to be coming in
the near future so be sure to subscribe
and hit that notification Bell so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
MCU news so let's first started off with
what Bob Iger said about the reduced
output coming from Disney in general and
specifically and particularly with
Marvel he literally mentioned Marvel by
name so during the quarterly earnings
call for Disney yesterday Bob Iger
stated we've reduced volume we've
reduced output particularly at at Marvel
he also teased that they're going to
start focusing on some of its stronger
franchises going forward stating I'll
leave it at that meaning we might be
focusing more on the core Avengers again
and not so much on these other
characters that have been newly
introduced over time that maybe won't go
on in the MCU to play really important
roles it looks like they are basically
reducing the output of new characters
that they are introducing into the MCU
and going to focus more on the core
character characters that everybody has
been used to now I like this plan but I
also kind of don't like it because they
should continue to introduce new
characters to the MCU because some of
these original characters and some
characters that have been around for a
while at this point in time aren't going
to be around forever but I do agree that
they should focus on kind of core and
bigger characters like the Fantastic 4
and the X-Men nothing against the echo
series I think I enjoyed it a little bit
more than most people did but it seems
like a story that isn't going to really
impact the MCU moving forward and if
they are trying to reduce output it
seems like stories like that and series
like that are probably going to get cut
and they're going to get cut so Marvel
can focus on actual Avengers X-Men and
Fantastic Four members also I just
wanted to address that the Thunderbolts
movie is not cancelled we'll get into
that in a bit but a lot of people have
been stating that this morning because
Bob Iger failed to mention the
Thunderbolts and blade when talking
about 2025 movies but we'll get to that
in just a bit so let's dive into the
official release date for film films
that Disney put out yesterday going
through 2024 to like I mentioned 2031
but for 2024 they have the first Omen
Kingdom of the Planet of the Apes young
woman and the Sea inside out too and
then on July 26th of 20124 we have
Untitled Deadpool movie so Deadpool has
not been delayed great news because you
never really know what could happen
especially after what Bob Iger said but
then we have alien Romulus Untitled
Disney movie The Amateur Moana 2 for
those Moana fans out there and Mufasa
The Lion King then we dive into 2025 and
again a lot of people were freaking out
because during the call Bob Iger did not
specifically mention the Thunderbolts or
blade on the call when talking about
2025 films however I think he just chose
a few films to mention for 2025 instead
of mentioning them all on the call which
you'll see here because on February 14th
of 2025 we have Captain America Brave
New World world so getting some pretty
big release date updates here then in
March we have an entitled Disney movie
and Disney's Snow White then May 2nd of
2025 we have the Fantastic 4 a lot of
news on this front lately it's recently
been officially confirmed that Pedro
Pascal is Reed Richards aka Mr Fantastic
sag s AG they have confirmed this by
accident it looks like on their website
for Pedro Pascal's bio where they put he
has recently joined the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and will begin filming for the
Fantastic 4 soon that has since been
removed from the website so we assume
they got a call from Marvel in may we
also have another Untitled Disney movie
then in June we have ilio and then we
have Moana which we assume is the
liveaction Moana starring The Rock but
then as we can see here we have the
Thunderbolts listed for July 25th of
2025 so the Thunderbolts is still listed
on this official release date slate for
Disney it has not been canceled and if
we go down just a little bit we see that
in August they have another Untitled
Disney movie but then in November
November 7th of 20125 they have blade
listed so the Thunderbolts and blade are
still on the release slate they have not
been canceled again I think Bob Iger
probably just chose a few movies to
mention that he's excited about for 2025
and didn't mention the Thunderbolts or
blade which could be a bad sign that the
movies might not be going according to
plan right now we know that they've had
to do a bunch of script rewrites and we
know the Thunderbolts recently lost step
young as century and they got a new
century now so perhaps he's just not
mentioning them because he doesn't
really know how they're going to turn
out hopefully great it seems like he
really is trying to make some pretty big
changes over at Marvel Studios along
with Marvel president Kevin feige so
hopefully they turn out good now in
2026 they have a ton of Untitled
projects 14 Untitled projects to be
exact they have Untitled Disney disy
Marvel Pixar Disney Disney Star Wars
Pixar Disney Marvel Disney Disney Marvel
Disney animation and Star Wars again so
two Star Wars movies and four Marvel
movies three are Untitled but there is
one that is titled the next Avengers
film which they still have listed as
Avengers the King Dynasty and this is
listed for May 1st of 2026 so the
previous report that we got from The
Hollywood Reporter either has changed or
was not true because Avengers 5 is still
the King Dynasty according to Disney now
that doesn't mean that they can't change
it but I'm going to go ahead and say
they stick with King the report was they
are going to kind of sideline King so
they could let all of the stuff that
happened with Jonathan major in court
kind of died down that way Kang the name
Kang didn't really have a negative
association paired with it because of
what happened when Jonathan Majors who
of course played King before they have
since let him go and now they are
recasting and this conf confirms that
they are sticking with King as the main
villain for the Multiverse Saga now I
might add that this could always change
they could change the name of the movie
but the fact that they put this on the
official release slate means that they
are pretty confident that it's going to
be the King Dynasty so as for now we'll
go forward assuming that the next
Avengers film is Avengers the King
Dynasty like they have stated here plus
they have three other Untitled Marvel
movies coming out that year February
13th 2026 aveng King Dynasty like I
mentioned May 1st but then July 24th of
2026 we have another Untitled Marvel
movie and then in November November 6th
movie then in 2027 they listed two films
one is the Untitled Star Wars movie this
seems to be the third Star Wars movie
there is two coming out in 2026 and one
in 2027 December 17th and then in May of
2027 we have Avengers Secret Wars with
the official release date of May 7th
2027 and this is actually a pleasant
surprise I think I even mentioned it in
a video yesterday that a lot of insiders
were thinking that we are not getting
Avengers Secret Wars until 2028 so a lot
of people including myself were bummed
that we were going to have to wait four
years until Avengers Secret Wars but now
only three which is still a while but
there is as we saw a lot of really
exciting stuff happening between now and
Avengers Secret Wars including Avengers
the King Dynasty and I'll just add this
in here for the Avatar fans they do have
2028 29 30 and 31 films as a slot listed
below 2027 and on December 21st 2029 we
get Avatar 4 and December 19th in 2031
we get Avatar 5 with Avatar 3 coming on
December 19th 2025 so Avatar 3 in 2025
Avatar 4 in 2029 and Avatar 5 in 2031 so
as you can see Disney and Marvel have a
lot of plans right now and on the
official Walt Disney Studios website for
the media kits for the Press members
they still have Daredevil Born Again
listed for 2024 so for those who are
wondering when exactly Daredevil born
again is going to come out it still
looks like it's coming out in 2024
despite everything being pushed back a
lot so a lot of big reveals today we
have the official release date for
Avengers Secret Wars and the title for
Avengers 5 we have discovered is still
Avengers the King Dynasty meaning Marvel
is indeed still going to focus on Kang
and they will recast him and it's really
great to have that clarity now we don't
have to wonder well who is going to be
the next villain or what is Marvel
Studios going to do in the meantime well
we know it sounds like the plans are
pretty much the same they're just going
to wait a little bit until the King
Dynasty comes out but then it'll still
be king the Conqueror so let me know
your thoughts about all of this news in
the comments down below please don't
forget to like this video And subscribe
to stay up to date on the MCU and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
automatically enter in our giveaway for
a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month you can find us on Twitter
and Instagram and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof
woof